what's up guys i'm dave klein and
welcome to my spoiler filled elden ring
lore series today we'll discuss a
prodigy who would become a queen and a
school influenced by the stars
today we discuss ranala queen of the
full moon and the academy of rhea
lucaria it all began with those who
would look up at the stars above
astrologers who preceded the sorcerers
established themselves in mountaintops
that nearly touched the sky and
considered the fire giants their
neighbors we can find remnants of the
astrologers looking out at the stars all
over the lands between via crescent
bowl-shaped monuments or perhaps moon
dials set up on mountains and cliffsides
that collect starlight shards while i'm
not certain of the exact purpose of
these one is found on an altar in the
royal moongazing grounds of karya manor
indicating that it was incredibly
important to astrologers considering
they do look so similar to sundials it
could be that these served a similar
purpose
but for the moon as starlight shards are
regularly found in these perhaps they
were used for that very purpose looking
at the preceptor's big hat we can find
markings at the bottom that are
movements of the stars drawn on the
inside of the brim indicating the
general importance of etching out the
night sky his hat also further tells us
that glintstone sorcerers are the
descendants of astrologers a fact that
the karyans remain aware of even if
their fate has been long severed from
the stars oddly from the astrologer set
astrologers would read fade in the stars
and are said to be heirs of the
glinstone sorcerers but alas the nice
guys no longer cradles fate indicates
the astrologers came after the glinstone
sorcerers but given other descriptions i
think it could be referring to modern
day astrologers as the sky isn't
cradling fate fate has already arrived
via the outer gods as the astrologers
were studying the stars they seemed to
accidentally discover sorcery through
founding reign the eldest primeval
sorcery said they've been discovered by
an ancient astrologer thought to be the
founding glenstone sorcery the glimpse
of the primeval current that the
astrologers saw became real and the
star's amber rained down on this land
at some point the study of stars became
concrete as various astrologers learned
to harness the powers of the stars into
sorceries in particular master azur and
master lucette azur who was focused on
studying comets and lusat who studied
meteors
ah
then you have seen master azure
master azure was a founding glimstone
sorcerer
and my first teacher
a stern judge of men
master lusat is another founding
glimstone sorcerer and thus master lusat
along with master azor would also help
contribute to the founding of the
academy of rail lucaria and liyernia
becoming grand masters of the academy
i've seen that structure to the north
towering over the water
that's the academy of reya lucaria
where we study glindstone sorceries the
schools seem to be founded by masters
such as azor and luca as well as
sorcerers from both caria and celia we
can see this by looking at the academy
of rail lucaria crest and for this i
want to thank quailog as it was thanks
to her digging into the various sigils
that helps make this apparent the
academy of ray lucario crest has
elements reminiscent of both karya and
celia's sigils with the top more
kinderkarya and the bottom somewhat
resembling celia mind you i'm fairly
positive at this point karya was just a
town or family of sorcerers similar to
how celia is a town of sorcery and not
yet royal when students entered the
academy of rail lucaria they would first
learn the most basic of spells and
sorceries those based around glintstone
they were given a real lucarian robe
upon entering robe worn by rey lucaria's
magic scholars those who dedicate
themselves to the study of glenstones
formed from starry amber received this
modest yet elegant deep blue garb along
with their vows of virtue and austerity
but with extended life one is apt to
forget old vows first they would learn
glenstone pebble the most basic linstone
sorcery of the academy of real lucaria
this is a universal first step on the
journey to true knowledge of sorcery and
eventually they will learn more powerful
sorceries such as great glinstone shard
before either moving on to a conspectus
or washing out those unworthy of the
stone crown typically end their brief
journey into sorcery here if a student
should succeed in their studies more
advanced schools of thought would open
up to them based around their master's
very own ideologies students who studied
and mastered these ideologies would wear
crowns depicting the faces of the
masters who began the schools of thought
in order to help them internalize the
teachings and perform better of these
teachings there is the carlos conspectus
the carlos conspectus is the oldest of
the academy's lineages of study begat by
the sorcerer azur scholars who follow in
his footsteps pursue the mysteries of
comets this is reflected in the
teachings of the conspectus spells like
comet the greatest of the carlos
conspectus's sorceries that only a very
few sorcerers have ever mastered and the
less powerful glenstone comet shard were
a part of his conspectus there's also
shard spiral which was the product of a
failed attempt to create a new comet
there was the liviness conspectus the
lineage of the liveness conspectus began
with the sorcerer lucette and its
adherents continue his study of meteors
thus starshower and glindstone stars
were taught in this conspectus with
glenstone stars attracting sorcerers
from celia town of sorcery eventually
with the coming of ranalla a new school
the lazuli conspectus scholars of the
lazalai conspectus study karyn's
sorceries a heterodox pursuit that views
the moon as equal to the stars there was
also the haima conspectus scholars of
the jaime conspectus sought the power to
quell conflict and to this end studied
the sorceries of cannon fire and the
gavel jaime was the adjudicator of the
academy and his sorcery employed might
as a means to quell conflict finally the
twin sage conspectus who didn't focus on
a specific area of study but multiple
scholars of the twin stage conspectus
were the elites of the academy permitted
to study and excel in sorceries of all
kinds those who study the twin stage
conspectus are the academy's elite
capable of mastering the glenstone comic
shard and crystal burst sorceries other
glenstone crowns were bequeathed to
students who excelled as well with them
not necessarily being tied to specific
teaching for example it seems some
female students who excelled were given
a witch's glinstone crown this gentle
looking crown was granted to a scholar
who excelled in her studies which also
merited the title of which
interestingly as i've been tying these
to famous sorcerers whose pictures we
can see lining the walls of ray lucaria
i think this glintstone crown is
actually supposed to represent sorceress
selen you can see me standing underneath
her painting here with her glintstone
crown how do i know this is probably
selling well that's actually thanks to a
video from zully the witch zoli posted a
video unmasking every npc and in it we
can see this is what selin's face looks
like
look familiar it suggests selen was the
first to get this distinction
finally there is the hierarchus
glenstone crown which i could be
mispronouncing by the way which was
granted to scholars who engaged in
nomadic study away from the academy
there was also the crystal cadre and the
study of crystallines crystal burst for
example is a sorcery of the crystal
cadre a group of sorcerers who pursued
the wisdom of stone the secrets locked
in the faint cognition of the
crystallines not much is known about the
crystallines or at least i don't know
too much about them so if you have
theories or thoughts let me know in the
comments what we do know is that the
crystallines would seem to be an alien
race shattering crystal is a sorcery of
the mysterious crystallines the
crystallines are inorganic beings yet
they live they cleave close to the
ideals of the primeval current and as
such they are revered guests of the
sorcerers magic downpour tells us that
it was a sorcery of the carrion royal
family said they'd been taught by the
crystallines to mark the swearing of the
old concorde
so between these i have to imagine that
the sorcerers and crystallines agreed to
live in harmony and help each other the
sorcerers revered and studied the
crystallines with the crystal cadre in
particular trying to understand them the
inscrutable crystallines have but one
clear purpose to safeguard their
crystals onto the end one theory posits
that they yearn for the return of their
creator who will carve for them new
brethren
so perhaps the sorcerers as part of
their agreement tried to help the
crustalians to this end we can find
crystallines in the crystal cave and
real lucario crystal tunnel where the
sorcerers dug for glintstone and likely
worked alongside these crystalline after
all a crystal staff is a staff fashion
from pure crystal indeed impossible for
a human
the crystalline's faint cognition is
known as the wisdom of stone this staff
can only be wielded by those of
intellect high enough to grasp such
wisdom
in order to better facilitate
understanding amongst the students tara
magiko is cast on the academy grounds
terra magica draws an academy sigil upon
the ground raising the magic strength of
those within once the sigil would be
cast from the highest belfry of the
academy covering the entire
institution's grounds this spell allows
such vivid experience of spell casting
success it turns many of fledgling into
a true sorcerer and a flash of newfound
understanding the academy was even
around long enough to begin to
facilitate its own legends lacrima the
long-tailed cat features in the fables
of rail lucaria in which she is
described as a fairy cat who was fond of
playing in the great bell tower
once the school was founded nobles from
around the lands between would send
their children to study at the academy
after all this was before the earth tree
ruled so it had its own renown and even
during the rule of the urgery there was
a period where the academy and capital
were united so it's pretty possible
lords within the capital might send
their children here the noble sorcerer
ashes both showcased this and showed
that not everyone was talented enough to
don a crown spirit of a nobleman who
once asked to be given a place at
reyelucaria to learn glinstone's
sorceries his talents were insufficient
to be worthy of donning the stone crown
however and he is only capable of using
the most rudimentary sorcery many of the
sorcerers who failed or didn't try hard
enough were sent to the academy's
glenstone mines the academy does not
welcome the indolent it was in these
mines the crystal cave located directly
beneath the academy of raildukaria and
the reya lucario crystal tunnel that the
academy would mine for its many
glimstones we can also see similar mines
in celia so it's possible the practice
of mining for glinstone began before the
founding of the academy here failed
sorcerers would use a digger staff to
extract linstone from crystal tunnels
the staff itself is a tool used to mine
and the feral is also embedded with
glinstone these miners would use the
spells of shatter earth and rock blaster
to help facilitate their mining which
was seen as shameful to anyone still
studying in the academy shatter earth
was a stone digger sorcery used by the
glinstone miners of the crystal tunnel
at the academy use of this sorcery was a
stigma that marked out failed scholars
the study of glinstone was far-ranging
with the academy even employing
glenstone craftsmen who figured out ways
to utilize smaller clinton shards the
glenstone craftsman's cookbook tells us
that it's a record of crafting
techniques left by glenstone craftsmen
who serve the academy contains
information on faux sorceries such as
they were called the academy became such
a prominent feature in the lands that
the academy gay town was built around it
the academy of rail lucario towers over
the north while as base spreads the town
built around it you wish to know more of
lady ranala
she is queen head of the karyan royal
family and governor of the academy of
real lucaria
the great and beautiful full moon witch
when ronaldo was a child she was a
prodigy while most of the academy and
sorcerers were obsessed with stars
ronaldo focused her study instead on the
moon while the study of the moon was
initially considered lesser than to the
stars ranala made the academy see the
light
the young astrologer gazed at the night
sky as she walked she had always chased
the stars every step of her journey then
she met the full moon and in time the
astrologer became a queen
queen ranala encountered this enchanting
moon when she was young and later it
would bewitch the academy in fact she
was so adept at using these sorceries
she would end up becoming the master of
the academy of real lucaria in her youth
ronaldo was a prominent champion who
charmed the academy with her lunar magic
becoming its master she also led the
glenstone knights and established the
house of karya as royalty as i mentioned
before karya wasn't initially considered
a royal house but it was through ranala
becoming master of the academy that she
was able to establish her dynasty
showing just how incredibly influential
she was she was likely considered one of
the most intelligent of any who had come
to the academy she wielded a karyn regal
scepter the glintstone is known as
aquarium blue enhancing full moon
sorceries only those of the highest
intelligence may wield this the finest
of all glenstone staves at some point
after coming to the academy certain
reforms seem to be made for one we can
now see the influence of the moon on the
academy as a moon crescent pedestal can
be found near the debate parlor and
within a moon is prominently hung above
the center of the parlor of course as a
master of the academy paintings of her
likeness can be found throughout this
also could have been when the lazalite
conspectus was brought to the academy
these scholars who sought to master
karyn's sorcery instead learned to see
the moon as equal to the stars this robe
in the hue of the full moon signifies
their heresy study of the moon was
incredibly important to karya and
probably thanks to ranala at the top of
karya manor is the royal moongazing
grounds here we find chairs set up in a
circle around a small pool shape just
like the moon nearby an altar with what
i believe to be a crescent moon on top
for gathering starlight shards this
study of the moon became of the utmost
importance to karya after ronald became
master of real lucaria there seemed to
be developments in what some of the
sorcerers were studying that being the
graven school and study of the primeval
current which ranala specifically banned
the school of graven mages was
considered a nightmare that would
continue to haunt the academy the
primeval current is a forbidden
tradition of glenstone's sorcery those
who cleave to his teachings the act of
collecting sorcerers to fashion them
into the seas of stars is but another
part of scientific inquiry
considering the graven mages would quite
literally attach other sorcerers onto
each other to create some sort of a seed
i think you can understand why a
headmaster might forbid that realm of
study in fact two of the founding
members of the academy master lucat and
azor were both banished for this exact
thing
master lussat is another founding
glimstone sorcerer
and like master azure he was banished
from the academy
now he languishes in prison somewhere
since the grand masters azor and loose
that were driven from the academy no one
has achieved their formally held rank it
was for attempting to restore the
primeval current of blindstone sorcery
the toothless pedentry peddled by the
karyan royal family can rot for alika
i want glimstone sorceries that open our
minds unbound by terrestrial taboos
no matter what we give in return
and of course selen tried to do the
exact same thing putting sorcerers into
seeds hence why she was expelled stalin
was well known
the most promising sorceress in the
history of the academy
i followed her at school
but there may as well have been an ocean
between us but selan was expelled from
the academy
accused of unthinkable treatment of
certain sorcerers
under the name of the graven witch
i still don't believe the accusations
the illustrious selling would never do
such things
interestingly i actually think it shows
a good level of restraint from ranala
from software has a tendency to show
sorcerers seeking intelligence and
losing their minds by going too far by
discovering things we were never meant
to know
big hat logan from dark souls 1 is a
perfect example of this
so ronaldo had good reason to ban this
practice in the academy and by the way i
think it was rinalda as selin blames the
karyn royal family for the fact she was
stopped from studying and when she
thinks ronald is gone she excitedly
takes over to study the primeval
currents do you see this the queen of
carrier is no more
with the bodies of masters azir and usat
returned
the academy can hone the primeval
current
so that we
fallen children of the stars shall beam
with brilliance once again
for one selin is destroying other
sorcerers in the pursuit of her
knowledge and in the end
even destroys herself
additionally both azure and lusat ended
up going insane from the knowledge that
they would come to from the common azure
when azure glimpsed into the primeval
current he saw darkness he was left both
bewitched and fearful of the abyss
and we find him as a husk of his former
self
similarly from the stars of ruin when
lucia glimpsed into the primeval current
he beheld the final moments of a great
star cluster and upon seeing it he too
was broken
again similar to dark souls 1 sometimes
you can go too far
after ronald became head of the academy
she established karya as royalty and of
course herself as queen granala is queen
of the carion royals who govern the
academy but rinala herself is no demigod
but soon a war would break out one
between lane dell home of the
ever-growing golden order and the
academy of rail lucaria science versus
religion the first liernian war
radigan's glory burns red as his hair
american the golden order sent out
ratigan to lead the army against rail
lucaria in the first liarium war while
this is somewhat of a contentious point
in that some think american and radigan
were two different people who eventually
merged together i'm of the mindset that
radigan is and always was america and
that they're more so split personalities
while we'll discuss all of that later
for the sake of this video it's not a
crucial point
what is crucial is that it was ronald's
karyan knights who were truly able to
repel the attack the enchanted knights
anointed by the lunar queen were heroes
of the highest honors these knight
swords could serve as catalyst letting
them wield sorcerous battle skills
despite numbering fewer than 20 this
power made them a match for even the
champions of golden battle the karyan
knights never waver they use the
combination of weapons and magic like
glimp blade phalanx to repel the golden
army glimp blade phalanx was bestowed
upon the enchanted carrion knights who
combined this art with their
swordsmanship to maintain pressure upon
their foes striking in waves of steel
and sorcery not only that but ronald and
the karyn royals were able to call upon
trolls to aid them in battle
called into service when the queen
invoked an oath they swore the trolls
are treated as true knights of karya and
fight arm and arm with their human
comrades the great blade phalanx is one
of the sorceries of the karin royal
family used by the enchanted troll
knights they were comrades of the young
ranala bound by oath
ranala and the karyan royalty also used
trolls to serve as blacksmiths i am eg
a blacksmith who once served the karyan
royals
meanwhile it's likely this was when the
sorcerers first developed and used
marionette and avionite soldiers to
fight with them marinette soldiers were
crafted to serve the sorcerers for a
doll the only thing that matters is that
it does not break they would attack with
spiked spears and melee combat while
marionette archers were each equipped
with a pair of bows on the verge of
falling apart they are ill-disciplined
and attacked without warning they also
created avian nets to attack from the
sky spirits of marionette soldiers with
avian features that were created to
serve a sorcerer equipped with
long-hafted sides they also attacked
from the skies by lobbing fire pots can
sometimes malfunction when damaged while
the avian nets and marionettes were
prone to malfunction they did of course
provide more manpower while it could be
mistaken and these could have been
developed before or in a future war we
aren't given a specific timeline so i'm
going to place it here
but if you disagree feel free to let me
know why in the comments below
so between marionettes avianet's
sorcerers troll knights and especially
the karyan knights the academy of rail
lucaria and the karya royalty were able
to successfully repel radigan and the
golden orders invasion while we've heard
about the trolls who were treated well
by karya and the marionettes which were
simply animated by sorcerers before
moving on i do want to bring up a dark
side to all of this that being the
albanorics is my current belief and i
could be mistaken that it was the
sorcerers who created the albanorics by
combining a silver tier with sorcery and
after creating the albanorics they used
them as slaves according to the albanar
blood clot albanorics are life forms
made by human hands thus many believe
them to live in pure lives untouched by
the archery's grace so why do i think
they were made by sorcerers well the
academy gay town just outside the
academy of rail lucaria is filled to the
brim with second generation albanorics
and just south of this is the village of
the albanorics so by proximity alone
they seem to be related to the sorcerers
but beyond that color is an important
factor in eldon ring and the wolf riding
albanoric archers were a blue silver
male set which tells us that blue silver
is a metal born from the same mother as
the archers themselves and provides
protection from magic and frost blue is
most often associated with the academy
of rail lucaria and sorcery
not always but heavily so cerulean tears
after all are associated with focus and
magic meanwhile silver tears have
actually been used by those associated
with magic the larval tear which is
material required by the amber egg
cradled by ranala queen of the full moon
to birth people anew uses the core of a
creature mimicry known as a silver tear
as much as a substance as it is a living
organism in celia town of sorcery we
find a nox swordstress and priest who
use weapons made of silver tears the
knox flowing sword for example is a grim
weapon wielded by swordsmen of the
eternal city this chateau has a blade as
fine as a needle forged from the liquid
metal of a silver tier it is thoroughly
tempered until hardened
finally the blood of the silver tears
you can find in the likes of nakron
eternal city is the same white color as
that of the albinorics the silver tears
disguised as giant iron balls even drop
larval tears and silver tear husks
dropped by silver tears looks similar to
albanoric blood clots i also find it
interesting that the albanorics can use
spells which would speak to the idea
that sorcerers would have created them
the albanars harbors secret they cast
sorcery with their innate arcanus with
ankaria manor we find pidia the karyan's
servant oh
you
i am sorry your worship
i apologize for any offense given
i am pedia
servant to the korean royal family
i am charged with maintaining these
ghastly dolls
in exploring karya manor you can also
find another albanark on the first level
there's also loretta loretta was made a
guard for the karyon royalty and given a
war sickle originally given for service
as a personal guard to carry royalty her
silver mirror shield is similar to that
of the aubernaric shield and is a shield
of radiant silver festooned with amber
and carried by loretta the shape is said
to imitate that of a sacred drop of dew
which inspired the absurd rumor that
loretta herself was an albanoric while
the albinoric shield is similarly a tall
oval shield made of metal carried by
young albanariks the ornamentation
represents the primordial drop of dew
from which they are said to have been
created while it's not stated that
loretta is an albanoric and she doesn't
believe white when you hit her after all
it's possible she saw the plight of the
albanorics first hand and this is what
led to her deciding to do something
about it loretta once a royal carion
knight went on a journey in search of a
haven for all the narcs and determined
that the heilig tree was their best
chance for eventual salvation now i'm
not sure if the albanorics were created
before the eventual merger of the golden
order in reya lucaria but i do wonder if
the car and royalty were the ones who
created them and after the merger they
reviewed with disgust the knights of the
cuckoo do declare behold thy defiled
blood unlike any humor that flows in our
grand realm
i can't see any sorcerers particularly
caring about things like defile blood
until after the golden order merger the
albanoric's most formidable foes were
sorcerers after all
either way the albanorics were mocked
and looked down upon a far cry from
godskin this albanark hide mask is the
product of malicious mockery one more
thing to add before i move on according
to the ripple blade is a unique weapon
wielded by young albanorics the sword is
modeled after the ripples that are
thought to be the origin of their
species this may or may not help my case
that the sorcerers were the ones who
created them so let me know your
thoughts either way i was chatting with
quaylog who i highly recommend you check
out her videos and she suggested that
the ripple could have been the knox
creating the dark moon which in turn
created a gravitational ripple and the
origin of silver tears knox and noxtella
is a topic for another day but until
then again i highly recommend you check
her out as the old saying goes if you
can't beat him join him after failing to
take over karya and the academy of ray
lucaria by force radigan would end up
marrying ranala a political alliance
that would join the two houses although
if it was truly for love on radigan's
end or merely an alliance done
politically
i personally think is up for debate
either way it was celebrated across the
land
lord radigan was a great champion
possessed of flowing red locks
he came to these lands at the head of a
great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle
he soon repented his territorial
aggressions there
and became husband to the kharian queen
adegan once cleansed himself with
celestial dew
repented his territorial aggressions
and swore his love to rinala
the order of the urgery and the fate of
the moon were conjoined
and all the wounds of war
forgiven as the two great houses of the
lands between joined together it was a
moment for celebration across the land
the full moon crossbow was created a
one-of-a-kind enchanted crossbow of
exquisitely detailed craftsmanship made
to celebrate the matrimonial union and
reconciliation between the houses of the
archery and full moon lane dell and reya
lucaria the two rings dance when
reloading this weapon reveals true worth
when used with holy infused bolts
gifts were brought from both sides for
ranala it seems radigan brought with him
golden tailoring tools and a gold sewing
needle sewing needle made of gold one of
the tools brought by radigan when he
entered into marriage with ranala queen
of the full moon and joined the karyan
line this was also probably when radigan
gifted ronaldo her amber egg which
contained the great rune of the unborn
within it meanwhile ronaldo's family had
a darkmoon greysword they gave to
radigan a moon greysword bestowed by a
karyan queen upon her spouse to honor
long-standing tradition while radigan
would later change his into the golden
order greatsword upon leaving ranala
it's clear that this was originally a
darkmoon greatsword greatsword made of
light modeled after the elden ring
itself forged by king consort radigan to
proudly symbolize the tennis of the
golden order telltale's science betrayed
that this was once the grey sword
bequeathed to him by his first wife
ranala as the husband of ranala of karya
the red-haired ratigan studied sorcery
he also forced the instructors to wear a
mask of confidence which was a mask with
the mouse sewn shut with gold thread
when radigan married ranala he ordered
the karya magic preceptors to don these
masks to make it clear that all of their
matters were to be kept strictly private
what matters these were i'm honestly not
sure although it could be that they too
knew ratting in secret that he was in
fact america finally radigan brought
with him a red wolf to watch over the
academy who either by him or naturally
was trained in the ways of sorcery it
does seem like this union affected kari
in the study of the moon after all go to
the moon gazing ground zakaria and
you'll see the earth tree's light still
illuminated which would bleed into
seeing the night sky
according to the telescope it's an
astrology tool used by members of the
karine royal family a stolen part of a
larger instrument during the age of the
archery karine astrology withered on the
vine the fate once written the night
skies had been fettered by the golden
order with radigan ranala gave birth to
three children radon who would inherit
his father's red hair reichard and lady
ronnie who would find her own moon like
her mother however i'd like to focus on
each of those characters individually in
their own dedicated lore videos this is
probably around the time that radon in
particular would learn his gravitational
magic from an alabaster lord something i
find particularly interesting is that
i'm not actually sure if kario is on
friendly terms with alabaster lords or
not we actually find an alabaster lord
just outside of karya manor in a royal
grave ever jail this particular one has
meteorite which tells us the sorcery
originates from the onyx lords who had
skin of stone and were called lords in
reverential fear of their destructive
power
so it draws into question the
relationship of karya and these outer
beings while everything seemed well a
major development would change all of
that godfrey the first eldon lord had
his grace removed and was made tarnished
forced to leave the lands between
in america's own words
my lord
and thy warriors
i divest each of thee of thy grace
with thine eyes dimmed
ye will be driven from the lands between
he will wage war in a land afar
where ye will live
and die
however
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital
becoming queen america's second husband
and king consort
taking the title
of second elden lord
sadly her heart was broken when lord
radigan left her
while it's unclear as to what radigan's
true feelings were ronaldo was
completely heartbroken and lost herself
to misery when ratigan left her we can
even see a statue dedicated to ratigan
still by her in the grand library in the
end lady ranala was left alone
cradling the amber egg lord radicand
bequeathed her
now she devotes herself to it through
forbidden right
the grim art of reincarnation
when ranala head of both the academy of
rail lucaria and the karin royal family
lost her husband ratigan her heart went
along with him the great rune dwells
within the amber egg that was ravigan's
gift to her
to be honest i'm not exactly sure who
rinald is constantly reviving or i think
the key word here is reincarnating to my
best guess this could be a miscarried
child or a child she had that was lost
at a young age but to be clear this is
just my personal speculation what we do
know about these scholars is that
they're juveniles borne by the amber egg
of queen ranala the head of the real
lucaria academy yet their rebirth is not
without imperfections and thus do they
repeat the process eventually becoming
utterly dependent upon it rebirth is as
sleep to them and with each awakening
memory fades into oblivion
in order to do so she uses the great
rune of the unborn which ratigan had
gifted her an amber egg clutched by
ranala queen of the full moon great rune
of unborn demigods perfects those who
have been born anew children born in new
by ranala are all frail and short-lived
imperfect beings each and all
in order to be reborn ranala needs a
larval tear the core of a creature of
mimicry known as a silver tier as much
as a substance as it is a living
organism material required by the amber
egg cradled by ronaldo queen of the full
moon to birth people anew which i
already discussed in relation to the
albanorics with ranali clearly losing
her mind though is it thy wish to be
born anew
to become a sweeting
reborn of my beloved egg
the academy of raelicaria discarded her
and her ways
and then those of the academy realized
that ronaldo was no champion after all
the academy rebelled against the royal
family of karya and ranala did nothing
when the academy rebelled against the
royals
she was locked away in the grand library
fortunately for karya they had been
prepared for this very day from the
karyan knight shield carried by nice who
served the korean royal family excels
when facing magic or holy attacks just
who were these knights preparing to
fight and that seems to be answered in
car in retaliation this was the karyn
royal family's secret means to prepare
against the disloyalty of the academy
the moon and stars would one day go
their separate ways the academy of real
lucaria meanwhile purchased and paid for
mercenaries to attack on their behalf
the cuckoo it seems they themselves
didn't want to participate with their
own students outside of specific battle
mages from the jaime conspectus whenever
war broke out and the academy sealed
this gates only haimes scholars dared
venture outside seclusion is no way to
foster discovery it's only a convenient
form of escape they taught the cuckoo
knights scholars armament and shield
topped to the knights of the cuckoo by
the academy as payment for their
contract they brought with them cuckoo
grey shields to defend against magic
metal grey shield painted with appearing
cuckoo carried by the enchanted knight
sworn to the academy boasting high magic
damage negation this shield is used to
hunt down mages
our enemy is none other than karya
itself although it seems these
mercenaries intentions were a little
more malicious to take over the academy
as well
the cuckoo knight armor tells us that
its left breast is emblazoned with
appearing cuckoo once came their name
perhaps the bird shrewd gaze is an
expression of their refusal to be mere
servants of the academy something
important to note about the cuckoo bird
is that it actually has a malicious
meaning outside of the now infamous and
cutesy cuckoo clocks i'm going to read
this definition from wikipedia that
helps explain it i also want to thank
yuki desato rs for informing me about
this in my let's play the elven ring as
i think it helps broaden our
understanding of what's going on some
species of cuckoo are brewed parasites
laying their eggs in the nests of other
species and giving rise to the metaphor
cuckoo's egg and cuckoo's egg being a
metaphor for brewed peritocism where a
parasitic bird deposits its egg into a
host's nest which then incubates and
feeds the chick that hatches even at the
expense of its own offspring while
cuckoo can also symbolize very positive
things like unrequited love in japan i
think here in this case the cuckoo
represents the more malicious definition
although unrequited love is also fitting
with ranala so it really works both ways
the cuckoo circle depicts twin cuckoos
peering into a flourishing mass of
glinstone to a glimstone sorcerer the
body is a transient thing the cuckoo
alone knows its insignificance yet
watches over it all the same the
soldiers of reya lucari were also known
as the cuckoos they were given free
reign by the academy to wage wars they
pleased and they were infamous for their
rapacious ways so the knights of the
cuckoo left to face off against karya
manor but here they met resistance and
their demise
when the reya lukari academy turned on
the carrions the knights of the cuckoo
descended on this track
after levelling it
they carried on to the manor
the
were taken off guard
but their strength had not waned and
they repelled the knights onslaught
by conjuring an enchanted snare that
remains potent to this day
that is why i say tarnished
don't go near the manor
unless you wish to lie with the corpses
of the heedless knights of the cuckoo
karya manor set all types of traps for
the cuckoo from spells that would attack
armies who marched up to the castle to
enchanted hands potentially thanks to
reichard who stayed ready at the front
of the castle to leap down on those
unaware magic traps are everywhere
within the manor that will spring the
life should anyone step up on them and
attack meanwhile the korean royals also
harness magical puppets
ah
your worship allow me to be of use
other than the puppets there are some
very fine things up here in this
storeroom we find puppets in the
storeroom with pidia these puppets are
none other than puppets of rail
lucario's soldiers we also find summons
of these puppets guarding the second
level of the manor in fact to this day
crying puppets still exist at the
karya's study hall which is filled with
them and puppets seem to still be
fighting against rayo lucaria as we find
the two factions fighting along the
lyrinia highway north alongside
destroyed stone marionettes and
avionites
ah the puppets the puppets besiege us
finally at the top of their defenses are
lazy like linstone sorcerers those who
study karyn's sorceries and a karyan
night troll with it all culminating in a
projection of loretta while kary manor
seemed to take heavy losses they won out
near karya manor we find the resting
place of the contemptible cuckoos lost
in the siege of karya manor an
interesting item that i want to bring up
is the karyan filigree crest which tells
us that it's an honor said they've been
awarded to karyn knights who served as
direct retainers to the kingdom's
princesses now there's only one princess
ronnie daughter of ranala i do wonder
who the other kingdom princesses might
have been and if this might have been
when they were killed or something else
might have happened back at the academy
of ray lucaria rynala remained
undisturbed with ronnie casting a spell
to protect her creating an illusion of
ranala at her prime upon my name is
ronnie the witch
mother's rich lumber shall not be
disturbed by thee
foul trespasser
send word
far and wide
of the last queen of karya
and the majesty of the night she
conjureth
meanwhile on the outside a war even
larger than that of rail lucaria and
karya was about to take place the
shattering
the academy of reya lucario decided not
to get involved in this war and shut
down
only its doors have been closed for
quite some time now
after they declared they wouldn't
interfere with the shattering the
academy cast repelling seals on the east
gate leading to the capital
and the south gate leading here as you
might have guessed the seals are still
active
making entry to the academy impossible
without a glindstone key on the
academy's gate is a seal depicting the
sigil of the academy of rail lucaria
along with what looks like radigan's
crossed hatch symbol and the same symbol
we see on the wall of thorns and lane
del
and that is the sad state we as
tarnished find the academy and renal in
during the start of elton ring
thank you guys so much for watching this
lore video on renault in the academy of
rail lucaria this video really ballooned
as i started looking to properly look
into the academy which i felt was
important as ronald had such a major
influence on it i hope you enjoyed this
and if you did make sure to watch my
video on godric the grafted the lore in
these games is always an open discussion
so if you agree or disagree with my
thoughts feel free to let me know and
make sure to watch other youtubers lore
videos or check out other theories as
you might find one that makes more sense
to you and as always i'll see you guys
next time peace
[Music]
you